yes mean therapy asks does luenell
consider herself a [ __ ]
[Music]
we are amazing welcome to to the father
State YouTube live objecting the
Petersons apologize for the late start
but we are black everybody people are
late
we start our CP time it is midterm
election season and I have with me David
Pakman he is the beta male
[Music]
David thank you for coming I I can't
believe I'm here I know it's amazing
last time we didn't end well I know
right
do you remember I remember I had to kick
you off my show you kicked me off you
said I never have that idiot back on my
show you call me a girlie man yeah what
changed your mind about having me back
after the band that's really my producer
Oh a but you didn't even want me here
I don't love you okay yeah you love me
would I no longer be beta you'd become
alpha well something to think about
yeah amazing were you surprised that
after we off the radio show no really if
you didn't seem pleased with my answers
oh you were not answering that's what it
was what do you date I do and do you
find that it's difficult being a beta
male to find good women to date for sure
but it's abnormal for a man to be a
liberal or progressive is the sign of
being a beta male I didn't know how real
men are conservative Republicans you
know and strong in nature so I'm
concerned if you are the female who took
off her body
female body parts and a test a male body
parts who day I don't come hobby to male
body parties attack right it's still a
woman okay well you always that way or
do something happen along the way no
interestingly you know I'm glad you
asked that actually in in high school I
took a lot of sort of standard what we
would call like born biologically female
do your parents know that just education
system had their impact on you turned
you into a liberal do they know that it
had this impact on you know it's
interesting
this is why it's not good to allow
children to go to public schools mmm
tell me more because they are
brainwashing them they want to do it do
it and if you notice that Barack Obama
the father Messiah
you know he's to follow Messiah right I
don't know anything about that
Big Mama Michelle there'll be rats
there'll be thugs they'll be in jail and
so it's not a good not turn why do we
have to put up with the thirst you don't
have to that's it get in throw those s
Obi's out right
do you agree with that I don't they are
children of their lives a lot of people
it is I think have a lot a big family
but that's how evil the children are the
left are they'll destroy you to get what
they want and that's power and well I'm
curious if they're so powerful the
children of though they're not powerful
oh I think that's what they want I think
we will destroy it they will they'll
destroy you they'll try to do so okay
you get power got amazing now were you
disappointed to see the children of
Allah action that way you know what the
children of the lab trying to use me and
so I just want you to know not to trust
the children of the life oh come on no
proof okay no the lie I don't have
numbers but the children of the lies say
that because they want to deceive you
and then he bring in all this emotion oh
I was 30 years ago walking down the road
and a man raped me you don't believe
that that's a made-up lie too
Oh who made that up the children are the
laugh I said I'm sure another last
shittin yeah they made that up because
if you notice they state things over and
over and over and over and over again
the children of the lie black people go
into a trance
and then go in and then you yeah they
reach for daddy why eating chicken let
me suggest to you it's not really I
don't feel no waste or I feel like going
on and bless you
yeah praise the Lord praise the Lord
okay so okay we got a vote day smart
trash but they'll go with the
homosexuals I hope so
Andhra Democratic Party I hope so they
have been morally bankrupt well I just
rattled on the radical homosexual saw
that happened they're like oh no we
cannot have this and so whenever they
want to get the radical homosexuals and
that lines matter all of abortion people
the national organization of women who
hate men is are these really the most
important topics for you absolutely
okay so you're not been married you have
you're not married I've never been
married no kids in all right no no ohh
would it be a bad thing for our
conversation if I dated men I don't see
anything wrong with it but I know you do
you do not see anything wrong with it
with being attracted to men should I
assume you date boys so this is one of
those questions where the framing of the
question we have to talk about and I
raped them there's no question about
that
yeah I gotta ask you what is the man I'm
sorry
what is the man I do politics not
dictionaries are you a man I think so
and what is the man now I have to get
the old thing right but a man what is
this what you do define words yeah what
is the man I don't do definitions on my
show I'm not the right person to add it
what that's so boring do you know what
it is do I know what a man is I don't
know
amazing crazy to disagree isn't the the
children of the lie were screaming at
all about the earlie Kaling and mothers
okay all you're separating their mothers
from your children oh no don't do it do
you know do you agree with me that was
drama I'm not sure so all of a sudden
done if you want to go - no I really
don't know no I don't believe it okay I
won't accept it Paul you do know what
you won't say real issues and real
questions like this it's like it throws
the intellectuals are I agree amazing
and why did you think that why did I
think that no why did you think that why
didn't I know why did you think that
this isn't real you don't understand a
question I think I understand it what is
it about the question that's difficult
for you give me just a yes I'm black and
solo so give me a simple yes or no why
did you think that this graders are
watching right now I hope so and then
why didn't because they thought you
gonna keep my butt so you got to live up
to it ask you a question boy so you not
be an artist I'm speculating anymore you
for that do it do I get to talk about
okay no agreed that up the reason was
you've called me a girly man so many
times a week
oh okay that's because it's not because
I think you that I'm gay right
got it glad we clarified Oh this type of
conversation is going to be incredibly
informative for them so I'm glad to have
participated in it good man I think only
thing while Jesse was amazing and the
interlayer guy knife slavery was a
choice I mean would you feel you thought
that slavery was a choice or those
things I just told you right right
that's so ridiculous I don't notice him
it's just true listen to me yeah so
again I'm black and slow find you some
yes or knows so you do you know what
love is baby tomato you know what a beta
male is is so amazing
there's lots I feel amazing
incredible you like [ __ ] I'm sorry you
like let's I don't know any now you have
a that word of [ __ ] I don't think so
would you date us led to purge or it
it's not a term I use amazing my final
question oh do you know what a [ __ ]
here's where you see what no make sure
you watch the [ __ ] walk on the fall
estate thank you